hallo zusammen schön guten Tag
willkommen zu ZDF heute live die
Bundesregierung sitzt seit gestern in
Meseberg in Brandenburg zusammen und
versucht ihre Streitthemen zu klären
offiziell ist die Stimmung ja super aber
wenn man sich mal anschaut was da alles
im Hagen ist da muss man zumindest mal
ein Fragezeichen dran machen es gibt
wirklich viele Punkte in denen sich SPD
Grüne und FDP uneins sind wir erwarten
gleich Bundeskanzler Scholz
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck und
Finanzminister Lindner zu einer
Pressekonferenz die Pressekonferenz
werden wir uns dann gemeinsam anschauen
und ihr könnt gerne Fragen und
Kommentare schicken das geht am besten
indem ihr sie einfach in die Chats
postet oder an die Mail-Adresse schickt
dir jetzt gerade eingeblendet seht
wir sprechen dann nach der PK mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Andrea römerle
von der hertis School hertis School und
mit unserer Hauptstadt korrespondente
Nicole Dietmann in Berlin die sich eben
mit diesen speziellen Weibs in der Ampel
Koalition bestens auskennt Nicole wir
hören es geht gleich los hallo erstmal
wir sprechen gleich vorher schauen wir
mal ganz kurz was uns den aktuellen
Stand der Dinge zusammengefasst
Brandenburg zu genießen während das
Bundeskabinett auf Schloss Meseberg
getagt hat das war eine sehr gute
Kabinettsklausur
informativ instruktiv und Robert und
Christian werden das sicher bestätigen
auch sehr konstruktiv wir haben in
diesem ersten Amtsjahr viel erreicht und
um unser Land heilt durch die Krise zu
steuern die durch den russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine entstanden ist
Deutschland unterstützt die Ukraine
politisch humanitär finanziell und auch
mit Waffen
zugleich haben wir Deutschland
unabhängig gemacht von russischen
Energielieferung wir haben immense
Summen aufgebracht um die hohen
Energiepreise abzudämpfen und eine
Wirtschaftskrise abzuwenden damit
möglichst alle zurechtkommen das ist
gelungen und daraus ist ein Schwung
entstanden für unser Land diesen Schwung
des ersten Jahres wollen wir mitnehmen
zu der Aufgabe die uns nun vordringlich
beschäftigen wird die Transformation
unserer Wirtschaft hin zur
Klimaneutralität auch zur
Digitalisierung um zu erreichen dass wir
eine wettbewerbsfähige Volkswirtschaft
in den nächsten Jahrzehnten Schreiben
mit guten vielen Arbeitsplätzen aber
zugleich auch eine die eben diese große
Herausforderung bewältigt CO2 neutral zu
wirtschaften
was wir aus unserer Diskussion
mitgenommen haben ist dass das gelingen
wird dass wir diese große Aufgabe
Schultern werden und das Zuversicht
geboten ist wir haben auch verstanden
und sehr sorgfältig diskutiert dass das
mit wirtschaftlichem Aufschwung
verbunden sein wird mit Wachstumszahlen
und mit
Beschäftigungsperspektiven in
Deutschland die sicherlich uns die
Möglichkeit schaffen dass wir sagen
können in den nächsten Jahren wird
Deutschland das Problem der
Arbeitslosigkeit hinter sich lassen denn
es gibt sehr viel zu tun für das wir
sehr viele Frauen und Männer brauchen
die hierzulande sich einsetzen aber auch
aus anderen Ländern dazu kommen damit
all die Arbeit geschafft werden kann die
in Deutschland jetzt anfällt die Aufgabe
die wir vor uns haben darf nicht
unterschätzt werden es geht ja immer
darum dieses Ziel in 22 Jahren zu
erreichen
wir brauchen Tempo auch das ist etwas
über das wir gesprochen haben und wir
haben deshalb im einzelnen auch
diskutiert was das bedeutet ums was wir
machen müssen um Tempo zu schaffen bei
der Energieversorgung aus Sonne
Windkraft und Biomasse bei Planungs-
ich habe schon unlängst gesagt wir
müssen bis 2030 vier bis fünf neue
Windräder aufstellen pro Tag und pro Tag
umgerechnet mehr als 40
Fußballfelder voller Solaranlagen wir
müssen das Netz ertüchtigen die
Wasserstoffwirtschaft investieren und
bei der Elektromobilität Vorankommen das
ist wichtig für die Zukunft unseres
Landes aber eben auch der Punkt der uns
zuversichtlich stimmen lässt denn wenn
wir das schaffen wenn wir die
Produktionskapazitäten ausweichen
weiterhin wenn wir den Fachkräftebedarf
sichern dann wird es uns auch gelingen
dafür zu sorgen dass das für unser Land
eine gute Zukunft bedeutet wir haben uns
darum auch beschäftigt mit dem anderen
großen technologiethema
der künstlichen Intelligenz die jetzt in
aller Munde ist über die viele sprechen
aber die tatsächlich die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung unseres Landes und der Welt
komplett verändern wird damit sind
enorme Chancen verbunden auch für den
Energiebereich für die Mobilität aber
zum Beispiel auch für die
Medizinforschung und deshalb war es für
uns ganz wichtig mit sehr interessanten
Gästen über diese Fragen zu diskutieren
miteinander zu besprechen wie uns das
gelingen kann das künstliche Intelligenz
auch in Deutschland entwickelt wird und
im großen Umfang eingesetzt werden kann
für eine bessere Zukunft
meine Damen und Herren die Tage hier in
Meseberg haben noch mal deutlich gemacht
worum es jetzt geht wir müssen und wir
wollen mehr Fortschritt wagen wir
brauchen mehr Tempo und wir brauchen
Zuversicht das alles ist jedenfalls für
uns in der Bundesregierung die Aufgabe
die wir jetzt Schultern wollen die
Kabinettsklausur hat dazu auch einen
wichtigen Beitrag geleistet jetzt bitte
ich zunächst Robert und dann Christian
um ihre Worte vielen Dank sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die Abgeschiedenheit
von meseburg die ja auch eine gewisse
abgeschirmtheit bedeutet und die
Zugewandtheit in dieser Konzentration
einer Kabinett Klausur hat glaube ich
allen noch mal deutlich gemacht was es
für ein Privileg ist in der
Bundesregierung zu sein wie sehr wir
auch einander angewiesen sind und wie
sehr dass sich konzentrieren auf die
eigene Arbeit und vielleicht auch mal
das Abschaum der vielen Stimmen und Töne
und Forderungen und
Überlegungen die auf einen prasseln im
Zentrum steht wir sind im Land
verpflichtet und das hat diese
Verpflichtung hat die Gespräche
dominiert und ich denke dass wir mit
dieser Haltung auch jetzt rausgehen aus
dieser Klausur und alle Fragen lösen
werden zu den Gesprächen die heute
stattfanden eine Beobachtung der
Bundeskanzler hat das gesagt wir stehen
dass die Transformation angeht vor
großen Herausforderungen und man neigt
immer dazu die Herausforderung der
Zukunft an der Realität der
Vergangenheit zu messen
gerade mit Blick auf die künstliche
Intelligenz aber auch mit Blick auf die
Zahlen beim Ausbau der Transformation
der erneuerbaren Energien Elektrolyse
Wasserstoff und so weiter ist das
erkenntnisstiftend
es scheint immer so ein großer Berg zu
sein den man vor sich sieht aber
wenn man sieht und weiß dass die Zahl
von erneuerbaren Energien noch im Jahr
2000 also ungefähr die Zeit die wir noch
haben bis Deutschland immer neutral ist
0,1 war also faktisch nicht existent war
und alles ist erreicht haben in 25
Jahren aufgebaut wurde unter vor gar
nichts da war dann sollte uns vor den
nächsten 20 25 Jahren nicht bange sein
sondern wir sollten Sie sehen dass wir
mit den Skalen Effekten die es möglich
sind mit dem technischen Wissen dass da
ist auch mit den digitalen Möglichkeiten
alle Chancen haben große
Herausforderungen zu bestehen
und das gilt so denke ich auch für den
Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz im
gleichen Maße beide zusammen künstliche
Intelligenz die Digitalisierung unserer
Wirtschaft und neue Geschäftsmodelle und
die Transformation werden diesem Land
und auch Europa Wohlstand und Wachstum
für die nächsten Jahre und Jahrzehnte
bescheren es ist ein gigantisches
Industrie und Beschäftigungsprogramm
dass wir hier anschieben damit schaffen
wir die Klimaneutralität und sicherlich
auch die wirtschaftliche Stabilität die
dann zu einer demokratischen führen wird
für Europa und für Deutschland in den
nächsten Jahren
ja meine Damen und Herren es war eine
gute Klausurtagung des Bundeskabinetts
wir haben untereinander natürlich viele
Dinge im formalen Rahmen
besprechen können aber hier ist immer
natürlich auch die Gelegenheit dass man
bei informellen
Gesprächen das eine oder andere klärts
oder eine Perspektive erweitert und das
hilft dann auch für das politische
Tagesgeschäft in den nächsten Wochen in
Berlin wir hatten spannende Gäste
gestern Ursula von der Leyen als
kommissionspräsidentin wie Sie wissen
hat Einblick gegeben in ihre nächsten
Planungen sind ja auch Vorhaben in
Brüssel die von großer Bedeutung für
unser Land sind
gegenwärtig in Begriff abgeschlossen zu
werden und heute haben wir uns ja wie
sie auch gehört haben beschäftigt mit
der Energiewende und der künstlichen
Intelligenz
zwei sehr große Herausforderungen für
unsere Gesellschaft die aber
chancenreich sind das will ich gar nicht
im Einzelnen wiederholen aber uns wurde
auch deutlich gemacht sowohl mit Blick
auf die Energiewende als auch mit Blick
auf die künstliche Intelligenz welcher
enorme Kapitalbedarf hier besteht und
die Gäste haben unterstrichen es geht
hier vor allem auch im privates Kapital
nicht nur um die notwendigen Mittel des
Staates etwa im Bereich der
Grundlagenforschung und bei der
Unterstützung der Transformation sondern
darüber hinaus eben das private Kapital
und deshalb ist es ein ja kein Zufall
aber es trifft sich gut dass wir jetzt
gerade also in diesen Tagen in dieser
Woche das zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz
Abschließen das Finanzministerium und
das Justizministerium haben einen
Entwurf für ein Gesetzgebungsvorhaben
erarbeitet so wie die Koalition das ja
auch beschlossen hatte mit dem wir
private Finanzierungsbedingungen in
Deutschland in der Breite verbessern
wollen und passt gut eben zu unseren
Gästen die auf den privaten
Finanzierungsbedarf hingewiesen haben
wir wollen also jetzt sehr rasch in die
Ressort Abstimmung gehen vorher ist ja
die sogenannte früh Koordinierung also
insofern sind wir im Tagesgeschäft ganz
gut passend zu dem was wir hier in der
Klausurtagung gemacht haben
ich habe sogar zwei wenn ich darf Helena
sie haben gesagt man hatte genug Raum
für informelle Gespräche und ist da auch
bei dem einen oder anderen vorangekommen
vielleicht können Sie alle drei einmal
sagen
wobei und habe ich an sie noch mal eine
Frage es gibt ja heute eine Studie aus
im Ministerium das ist möglicherweise im
Worst Case Szenario 900 Milliarden Euro
kosten könnte die Folgen der Klima des
Klimawandels aufzuwiegen wäre reagieren
sie auf diese Studie was müssen da die
Antworten sein danke vielleicht kann ich
sagen wir haben in der Tat wie der
Finanzminister gesagt hat wie Christian
das eben formuliert hat viele Zeit
gehabt auch Sachen informell miteinander
zu sprechen das ist ganz gut so bleibt
natürlich informell auch so dass wir sie
da nicht alle dran beteiligen wollen
aber ich kann den Berichten dass wir
auch Fortschritte gemacht haben bei
vielen Fragen die wir im Alltagsgeschäft
verhandeln und da sind auch ohnehin die
Pläne so dass wir jetzt in ganz kurzer
Zeit versuchen verschiedenste Vorhaben
zum Abschluss zu bringen das passiert
stattgefunden hat ist ein sehr fühlbares
unterhaken und auch die gemeinsame
Überzeugung dass das gelingen wird
zu den 900 Milliarden
wir sagen immer
Klimaschutz aber trivialerweise schützen
wir überhaupt nicht das Klima sondern
die Menschen die Menschen auf der Erde
die Menschen in unserem Land nicht nur
für vor Katastrophen wie dem Aartal das
dann durch Naturkatastrophen und
unkontrollierte Wetterphänomene Tod und
Zerstörung bringt und natürlich hohe
Kosten aber vielleicht sind die dann
erstmal zweitrangig sondern viele
Menschen haben damals ihr Leben verloren
und ihre Heimat wieder zu Hause und
natürlich sind die strukturellen
Anpassungskosten vom Küstenschutz bis
zur Landwirtschaft zu beziffern
Versicherungswirtschaft alle gleich und
zielverbände kennen die hohen Kosten
lange Rede kurzer Sinn wir sind gut
beraten diese Kosten gering zu halten
und gut beraten gleichfalls eben schon
von uns allen dreien ausgeführt die
möglichen Gewinne also die ökonomischen
Vorteile als starke Industrienation auch
die nächste Phase der industriellen
Entwicklung nämlich eine klimaneutrale
Produktion zu entwickeln hier in unserem
Land zu halten also die Gewinne zu
halten und die Kosten zu vermeiden
Bundeskanzler sie haben gestern im
Eingangsstatement und auch jetzt wieder
viel von Zuversicht gesprochen die sie
stärken wollen dazu gab es ja gestern
auch Vorträge von Fachleuten was haben
Sie denn da gelernt wie wollen Sie denn
persönlich die Zuversicht stärken die
Bevölkerung ist ja doch etwas
verunsichert aufgrund der aktuellen
Situation diese Frage würde ich nicht
nur gerne ihnen stellen sondern auch den
beiden Ministern habe ich und Lindner
danke schön
Zuversicht entsteht dadurch dass man
sich ehrgeizige Ziele setzt aber auch
sicher ist dass man sie schaffen wird
und diese Ziele erreichen wird und das
ist genau das was wir ja hier dann auch
weiter verhandelt haben ich habe das
schon gesagt großer wirtschaftlicher
Aufschwung Wachstum kann verbunden sein
mit der wirtschaftlichen Veränderung die
notwendig ist damit unsere Industrie wie
man neutral wirtschaften kann wenn wir
die Energienetze die
privatwirtschaftlich betrieben werden
überwiegend wenn wir die
Erzeugungsanlagen alle errichten in
Deutschland die dazu notwendig sind dann
sind das milliardenschwere
privatwirtschaftliche Investitionen die
gleichzeitig viele Arbeitsplätze
schaffen viele gute
Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten schaffen und
dafür sorgen dass es neue
wettbewerbsfähige Technologien aus
Deutschlands in aller Welt zu kaufen
gibt und diese Zuversicht dass die
dass es möglich ist dass es in 10 20 30
Jahren für ein Land wie Deutschland
weiterhin gilt dass wir vorne dabei sind
in der Weltwirtschaft dass wir unsere
Kraft erhalten können das auch jeder
Bürger und jede Bürgerin davon ausgehen
kann dass das auch für sie selber gut
ausgibt die ist es die wir durch unser
tätiges Handeln stärken können und das
ist auch das worüber wir geredet haben
stimmt einfach
vielleicht eine Ergänzung aus den
Vorträgen aus dem Kopf
memoriert es gab ein Zusammenhang den
ich entscheidend fand zu erkennen dass
nämlich einerseits die Erwartung an den
Staat an die Regierung zu helfen
irgendwann auch schnell wieder zu einer
Enttäuschung führen kann wenn man sich
ja nicht selber geholfen hat so einen
Art Kreislauf der gegenseitigen
erwartungsentauschungen und der muss
durchbrochen werden und wenn ich auf das
letzte Jahr Blicke dann ist er
durchbrochen worden dass wir hier stehen
Deutschland so da steht wie ist steht
ist nur gelungen weil viele Menschen
Unternehmen Betriebe die Kommunen die
Länder und ein Teil hat sicherlich auch
die Bundesebene von Parlament bis zur
Bundesregierung geschaffen ihren Beitrag
geleistet haben und einen eigenen
Beitrag zu leisten und auch das
anerkannt zu bekommen das zu merken
Selbstwirksamkeit zu erfahren ist
wahrscheinlich der gelernte beste Weg
für Zuversicht und Zukunftsgestaltung
Willen
ich habe eine Frage an den
Finanzminister bei den informellen
Gesprächen hätte ich ganz gerne gewusst
ob denn das Delta was sie haben für den
Bundeshaushalt 2024 ein bisschen kleiner
geworden ist können Sie uns eine
Größenordnung nennen es war ja vorher
mal von 80 Milliarden die Räder auf wie
weit sind Sie runtergekommen und Habeck
eine Frage wegen der amerikanischen
Subventionen sie hatten ja mal einen
industriestrompreis ins Gespräch
gebracht ist das eigentlich für Sie die
notwendige Antwort damit die Deutschen
und europäische Industrie Wettbewerb
mithalten kann mit den amerikanischen
Eier Race Subvention
Herr Winkel wir haben keine
Haushaltsgespräche hier auf Schloss
Meseberg geführt und ehrlich gesagt wenn
wir sie geführt hätten könnte ich sie
nicht im Einzelnen darüber unterrichten
wie Sie sicherlich Verständnis hätte
hätten aber hier gab es keine Anlass
dafür denn die erste Runde der Gespräche
mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Kabinett ist bereits abgeschlossen jetzt
konsolidiere ich den aktuellen Stand den
wir haben und dann gehen wir in die
Finalisierung des kabinettsens
anders als Europa als die USA wo ja Text
cred ist also Steuergutschriften
verteilt werden fördert Europa in der
Regel Investitionen also Zuschüsse am
Anfang das heißt die operationellen
Kosten werden kaum oder gar nicht so
funktioniert das ist ein
Wettbewerbsnachteil das muss man so klar
sagen in den USA ist das anders geregelt
wenn man
sich anschaut was wir haben was wir
können ergibt sich daraus einen
Bestandteil für einen
industriestrompreis in den werden wir
sehr zeitnah auch in den
Rechtsverordnung die notwendig sind
anschieben das heißt die Vorteile der
erneuerbaren Energien die hier sehr
günstig Strom produzieren die
Gestehungskosten liegen bei 5 bis 9 Cent
vielleicht und dazwischen findet sich
dann jeweils der Korridor nach
geografischer Gegebenheit die voll über
den Unternehmen ankommen zu lassen das
wäre ein Bestandteil eines
industriestrompreises aus dem Markt
heraus
das werden wir sein das werden wir auf
den Weg bringen natürlich müssen die
Erneuerbaren gebaut werden vor allem
offshore stellt denn der große Menge
Energie da die dann über sogenannte
Direktverträge Power purchasings dann
den Unternehmen zu Gute kommen können
und ob auf dieser Treppe dahin ist diese
Mengen zur Verfügung gestellt sind noch
weitere
Deckelungen möglich sind oder nötig sind
darüber werden wir reden aber den Teil
den ich in meinem Ministerium leisten
kann als industriestrompreis Bestandteil
den werden wir schnell auf den Weg
bringen
vielen Dank mohammed ist mein Name ich
bin von alte sera und ich habe zwei
Fragen ob ich darf der Christian Sie
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben mehrfach
handgekündigt dass Deutschland die
Ukraine unterstützen wird solange das
nötig ist und das Putin seine Ziele in
die Ukraine nicht erreichen darf heißt
das dass Deutschland die Ukraine dabei
unterstützen wird wieder das gesamte
Land zurück zu gewinnen also auch zum
Beispiel
seit dem kriegte aus der russische
respektive Russland gehören zweite ein
sehr Doktor habe im letzten Jahr wurde
in Deutschland für unternommen um die
Abhängigkeit Deutschland
beenden wie weit ist Deutschland zur
Zeit unabhängig von den russischen Geist
und wie sieht's in der Zukunft aus z.B
im nächsten und übernächsten im Winter
vielen Dank
schönen Dank für Ihre Fragen es ist aber
alles gesagt wir unterstützen die
Ukraine solange wie das notwendig ist
wir sind in Europa im kontinental Europa
insbesondere das Land das am meisten tut
mit finanzieller humanitärer Hilfe aber
eben auch mit unseren Waffenlieferung
mit der Ausbildung die wir hier
organisieren mit der Organisation von
Reparatur und natürlich auch mit den
notwendigen munitionslieferungen wir
haben immer mit all unseren Freunden und
Verbündeten klar gesagt dass wir keine
Entscheidung über die Köpfe der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine hinwegtreffen
werden deshalb beschränkt sich das was
wir tun können gegenwärtig darauf diese
Unterstützung zu gewährleisten und auch
immer wieder den russischen Präsidenten
aufzufordern das zu tun was für eine
friedliche Entwicklung und verzichtbar
ist nämlich dass er Truppen zurückzieht
wir sind am Anfang des letzten Jahres
noch mit Gaslieferung von Russland aus
Russland von über 55 Prozent versorgt
worden das ist jetzt so hingenommen in
Deutschland das ist gut gegangen ist
aber ich will noch einmal sagen dass es
eine gigantische Leistung dieses Landes
und zu aller Beteiligten ich habe es
eben schon gesagt und eine Leistung die
auch erbracht wurde weil viele Menschen
ein Preis dafür bezahlt haben die hohe
Inflation es ist wegbrechende
Energiemengen die künstliche Verknappung
die Putin dem Land aufgezwungen hat all
das ist ja nicht folgenlos geblieben
mich erinnere an die Diskussionen und
die Debatten die wir letztes Jahr hatten
aber es ist abgewendet worden noch
einmal das ist eine herausragende
Leistung die hier in großer Solidarität
erbracht wurde entsprechend sind wir im
Moment nicht abhängig von russischen
Gaslieferungen es mag sein dass über die
lng-terminals der Nachbarstaaten über
die ja gasmen kommen russische Moleküle
in dem Gas Mix sind das ist wieder zu
kontrollieren noch auszuschließen
die deutschen Unternehmen kaufen aber
kein lng-gas bei russischen Unternehmen
oder in Russland ein insofern ist es
eine leicht wäre es eine leicht zu
ersetzende
molekülbestandteils
wie soll ich sagen
Bestandteil des Gases muss also im
Prinzip sind hier unabhängig von
russischem Gas und für die nächsten
Winter ist die Situation
insofern eine andere dass die Speicher
so sieht es ja im Moment aus deutlich
höher gefüllt sind als zu Beginn des
letzten Jahres da haben wir mit 20%
speicherfüllstand gestartet jetzt sind
wir bei knapp unter 70 und es ist noch
mal kalt geworden im März ich denke wir
alle freuen uns auf den Frühling aber
wir werden trotzdem gut in der 60er
Mitte abschließen und dann sollte es
auch möglich sein die Speicher zu füllen
über den Sommer ohne solche Preis zu
sehen wie wir sie im letzten Jahr
gesehen haben die merkt spiegeln das ja
schon also die Spot Märkte sind ja in
Anbetracht der Lage ungefähr
vor kriegsniveau bei unter 50 €
inzwischen angekommen und der Ausbau von
weiterer Infrastruktur drei haben wir
drei FSA Youtube Terminals geschaffen
Wilhelmshaven Brunsbüttel und Lubmin
weitere kommen dazu sollte ebenfalls
helfen genug Infrastruktur Importen von
Struktur in Deutschland zu haben um den
nächsten Winter etwas weniger Bank in
Siegen entgegen sehen zu müssen wie wir
als wir es beim letzten Winter getan
haben
sie rufen Reiber vom Spiegel hallo ich
muss noch mal eine Frage zu den efuels
Stellen im Besonderen an Herrn Lindner
das
Verkehrsministerium das ja von ihrem
Parteikollegen geführt wird hat ja nach
einem Dokument über das wir heute Mittag
berichtet haben dieser EU Einigung
bereits zugestimmt dort wurde von allen
Beteiligten Häusern von konstruktiven
Gesprächen gesprochen und dass man diese
Weisung zustimmen können ich frage mich
jetzt
warum hat dann die FDP dann diese
Einigung noch mal grundsätzlich zum
Anlass genommen das auf EU-Ebene in
Frage zu stellen und
offensichtlich geht es ja darum dass die
EU da einfach ein Fahrplan vorzulegen
hat und an den Kanzler und Vizekanzler
die beigestellte Frage was bedeutet
dieser Vorgang oder wie bewirten Sie
diesen Vorgang in Bezug auf die
Handlungsfähigkeit dieser Regierung
die Bundesregierung ist sich einig dass
wir davon ausgehen dass die Europäische
Kommission entsprechend dessen was in
den Erwägungsgründen genannt ist an
Vorschlag machen wird der darauf
gerichtet ist wie fühlt es nach 235
eingesetzt werden können das haben wir
übrigens knapp vor einem Jahr hier in
Meseberg in enger Diskussion mit der
Europäischen Kommission politisch
wirksam gemacht und jetzt geht es darum
dass klar ist dass das auch tatsächlich
kommt es geht also um nichts Neues
niemand kann das überraschen bereits im
sondierungspapier von SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP aus dem Jahr 2000 und
2021 noch vor
Abschluss des Koalitionsvertrages war
klar dass für die Freien Demokraten
technologiefreiheit ein hohes Gut ist
das bedeutet es wird keine abschließende
politische Entscheidung getroffen über
die Antriebe in privaten PKWs und vor
diesem Hintergrund und in diesem
Semester haben wir uns in die
europäische entscheidungsbildung
eingebracht gegenwärtig gibt es nach dem
Entschluss des Europäischen Parlaments
und der sich daran anknüpfenden Debatte
keine Rechtssicherheit dass tatsächlich
auch nach
20530 Fahrzeuge mit Otto oder
Dieselmotor zugelassen werden können
wenn sie mit Öko Sprit betankt werden
diese rechtssichere klare Verbindung der
Entscheidung über die flottengrenzwerte
mit der neuzulassungs-
ich hätte
bitte eine Frage an alle drei Merlin
auch wenn Sie gesagt haben über ein
Haushalt ist es noch nichts entschieden
Kinder Grundsicherung ein ganz wichtiges
Thema wie sind denn da wie
zuversichtlich sind sie denn dass das
dass man dazu Potte kommt und wie ist da
der Stand der Dinge im momentan
100% zuversichtlich dass wir da wie sie
sagen zu Porto kommen es gibt eine
innere ministerielle Arbeitsgruppe der
verschiedenen Häuser angehören und wer
arbeiten dort ein gesetzgebungskonzept
das im Jahr
2025 in Kraft treten soll insofern ist
die Verbindung den gegenwärtigen
Haushaltsberatungen
fiskalpolitisch nicht zwingend ich
drücke mal so aus
es gibt
Einvernehmen dass wir die den Familien
zustehenden Leistungen
automatisiert
digitalisiert zur Verfügung stellen
diese Leistungen sind übrigens von der
Koalition deutlich erhöht worden die
Lebenssituation von Familien mit Kindern
hat sich also bereits jetzt ja deutlich
verbessert wir wollen das alle das
erhalten was ihnen auch zusteht alleine
die vollständige Automatisierung der
Bewilligung von den Menschen zustehenden
Unterstützungsleistungen wird
schätzungsweise einen finanziellen
Aufwand im Jahr
2025 von zwei bis drei Milliarden Euro
ausmachen können und das ist auch sicher
zu lassen
ich habe noch eine Frage zur Stimmung
das kursiert ja ein Video auf Twitter
ich wollte Fragen gab es eine
Schneeballschlacht und wenn ja wer war
an dieser Schneeballschlacht beteiligt
also ich habe ein Schneeball geworfen
aber wie sich das für ein Bundeskanzler
gehört auf niemanden
mal eine Frage an Herrn Lindner Sachen
Verbrennermotor warum sind sie
eigentlich so hinterher dass das eine
Zukunft geben soll für e-views also für
verbrennermotoren die mit synthetischer
Energie betrieben werden wenn doch
Experten sagen das macht eigentlich gar
nicht so viel Sinn weil der Aufwand viel
zu hoch ist auch die Industrie gar nicht
mal so mit den hufenchart dass sie
unbedingt diese Motoren dann haben will
oder betreiben will was treibt sie da
persönlich an danke schön was die
Einschätzungen der Industrie angeht ist
das ein vertieften Blick wert gibt es
unterschiedliche Stellungnahmen aber was
uns jedenfalls treibt ist das was Robert
Habeck eben zum Ausdruck gebracht hat er
hat ja mit dem Blick zurück 20 Jahre
zurück zum Ausdruck gebracht wo wir
damals standen bei den erneuerbaren
Energien und was sich verändert hat
innerhalb von zwei Jahrzehnten solche
Technologie Sprünge und großen
Veränderungen auch etwa in der
wirtschaftlichkeitsfrage die müssen
offen bleiben deshalb darf kein
Technologie Fahrt verschlossen werden
übrigens wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf
haben wir heute noch mal darüber
gesprochen das zu einem der Ziele die
wir bei der Transformation unserer
Volkswirtschaft Vorhaben gehört dass wir
um 23 15 Millionen Batterie elektrische
Fahrzeuge im Betrieb haben und das ist
eine gemeinsame Zielsetzung dieser
Koalition
so das war die Presse vonferenz von
Bundeskanzler Scholz Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck und Finanzminister Lindner zur
Klausurtagung der Bundesregierung auf
Schloss Meseberg und wir wollen jetzt
kurz dann doch noch mit unserer
Hauptstadt Korrespondentin Nicole
Diekmann in Berlin sprechen eben hatten
wir ja keine Zeit mehr liebe Nicole grüß
Dich wenn Du die wichtigsten Punkte
zusammenfasst welche sind das aus deiner
Sicht oder ich schaue meinem Chat Ursula
saatweber hatte uns auf Facebook
geschrieben dass sie mal gespannt ist ob
es da signifikante Einigung gibt
na ja ich glaube das wichtigste was man
in dieser Pressekonferenz signalisieren
wollte war das alles prima ist in der
Ampel das hat sich ganz zu Beginn schon
durch eine Kleinigkeit abgezeichnet
nämlich als der Kanzler die anwesende
Presse begrüßte und auch die neben sich
stehenden Minister und zwar mit ihren
Vornamen noch mal in die Debatte
einbrachte nämlich Robert also Robert
Habeck Wirtschaftsminister von den
Grünen und Christian Lindner FDP
Bundesfinanzminister da ist also ein
Trio das war das Signal dass man senden
wollte dass ich bei den Vornamen nennt
und duzt da gab es zwischenzeitlich mal
Verwirrung denn es gab ja einen
signifikanten einen außergewöhnlichen
Briefwechsel zwischen Robert und
Christian die einander eigentlich auch
duzen die miteinander streiten gerade
FDP und Grüne liegen ja in sehr vielen
Themen über Kreuz und ähm der erste
Brief kam von Robert Habeck eben mit
Adressat Christian Lindner und in diesen
Sitz der er plötzlich seinen
Kabinettskollegen wieder das heißt diese
Stimmung die man da heute
transportieren wollte die ist natürlich
nicht halb so gut wie es den Anteil
haben soll und ich glaube genau das
immer unter der Überschrift
Handlungsfähigkeit dieser
Bundesregierung plus eine sehr gute
Bilanz das ist das was wir heute sehen
sollten und was von dieser
Pressekonferenz und eben auch von dieser
Klausurtagung übrig bleiben soll und da
gab es ja eben eine ganz spannende Szene
also ja Robert Christian und Olaf aber
dem Finanzminister wurde eine Frage
gestellt da ging es um die
Verbrennungsmotoren und der Kanzler der
mir auch oft vorgeworfen wird dass er zu
wenig diese Regierung anführen würde hat
das Wort an sich gezogen
wie hast du diese Szene wahrgenommen was
hast du freundlich formuliert ich würde
fast sagen an sich gerissen genau da
sollte der Christian dann nämlich nicht
antworten sondern da wollte der Kanzler
selbst einmal sich so in Stellung
bringen evolut das ist gerade gesagt
sorgt im Moment für große Verwunderung
nicht nur innerhalb der Ampel es gibt
eigentlich einen bereits auf EU-Ebene
ausgehandelten Kompromiss bzw eine
Einigung bis 2035 ab 2035 sollen keine
Benzin und Dieselmotor getriebene neue
Fahrzeuge mehr zugelassen werden und nun
hat sich aber der Bundesverkehrsminister
Volker Wissing so wie Christian Lindner
FDP zu Wort gemeldet und droht damit
diesen Kompromiss diese Einigung zu
blockieren und besteht darauf dass
Fahrzeuge mit efuels durchaus weiter
zugelassen werden dürfen der
argumentiert die FDP wir haben es gerade
gehört mit
zukunfts- oder Fortschritts glauben da
gibt es aber auch viele die sagen das
ist der Versuch einer Partei die in den
vergangenen Landtagswahlen erhebliche
empfindliche Schlappen hinnehmen musste
sich zu profilieren und in der Frage des
Journalisten nach diesen efuels kam das
Wort Handlungsfähigkeit vor genau das
wurde indirekt in Frage gestellt und da
wollte Olaf Scholz wohl dieses Bild dass
er und die beiden neben ihm da
zeichneten Christian und Robert von der
Einigkeit und Handlungsfähigkeit lieber
nicht beschädigt wissen und dachte da
muss jetzt mal der Chef ran und genau
antwortete statt Christian Lindner der
sich dann aber nicht nehmen die sich
nach Scholz auch noch mal einzulassen
wäre dann gar nicht mehr zu Wort kam
aber auch angesprochen gewesen war war
Robert Habeck
und abschließend was würdest du sagen
ist dass dieser Kollektion gelungen
irgendwie dieses Gefühl dass es da doch
sehr sehr hakt auch atmosphärisch
aus dem Weg zu räumen
man muss ja mal der Fairness halber der
Ampelkoalition gegenüber sagen das ist
nicht die erste Koalition die
miteinander streitet die große Probleme
zum Teil miteinander hat wir haben das
schon ein paar mal gesehen auch gerade
nach kabinettsklausuren in Meseberg die
ja auch schon in den Vorgängerregierung
stattgefunden haben dass man vor allem
das atmosphärische was ja angeblich gar
nicht wichtig genug waren eine Rolle zu
spielen dann gerade bei den Abschluss
Pressekonferenzen in den Vordergrund
geschoben hat wir wissen aber auch ja
das Eltern vielleicht erstmal ein paar
Tage aber die Süddeutsche Zeitung hat
das mal zusammengerechnet diese Ampel
Koalition die noch nicht mal eineinhalb
Jahre im Amt ist und die sich mehr
Fortschritt Wagen als Überschrift über
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag gewählt hat die
hat sich in über 30 koalitions haben
oder rund 30 Koalition haben dermaßen
miteinander verhakt dass sie gerade
brach liegen das ist schon eine
Hausnummer und die lässt sich bestimmt
dich mit zwei Tagen Kabinettsklausur
auflösen
also da gibt es noch einiges zu tun wir
bedanken uns bei dir Nicole Dieckmann in
Berlin mach's gut tschüss sehr gerne
ja so viel erstmal zur Pressekonferenz
und jetzt wollen wir das Ganze in einem
größeren Kontext noch heben und das
machen wir gerne mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Andrea Remmele
von der hertis cool schön guten Tag
hallo ich grüße Sie Frau wie sehen Sie
das ist der Zoff in der Ampel wirklich
so groß oder ist das nicht vielleicht
auch ein Stück weit normal wenn drei
sich da zusammenraufen müssen
also ich würde sagen beides wir haben
natürlich eine Situation die wir bisher
noch nie hatten dass auf NAT also auf
nationaler Ebene auf Länderebene haben
wir natürlich durchaus schon drei
Koalitionspartner aber auf nationaler
Ebene hat mir diese Konstellation noch
nie wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht
dass die Union eine Partei ist dann ist
es auch so dass wir noch nie eine so
schwache Kanzlerpartei mit 24 Komma
quetsch Prozent hatten und zwei so
starke Juniorpartner also die Macht
Statik ist hier das eine und das andere
ist natürlich auch dass diese Koalition
wirklich enorme Tee und enorme Themen
vor der Brust hat
dieses
Koalitionsvertrag den sie im Dezember 21
geschlossen hat mehr Fortschritt Wagen
darauf hat er der Kanzler in seiner
Presse Erklärung jetzt auch noch mal
hingewiesen iesen dass man jetzt mit dem
dass man jetzt wirklich schnell und mit
Tempo mehr Fortschritt wagen möchte dass
man diesen diese Transformation in dem
neuen Koordinatensystem des Krieges
denken muss und es ist wirklich eine
enorme Herausforderung
absolut diese Koalition regiert ja
wirklich von Beginn an im
dauerkrisenmodus dazu schreibt Marco
redlich diese und die vorangegangene
Regierung findet er gut und sie hätten
es wirklich nicht einfach was würden Sie
sagen inwieweit macht das einen
Unterschied
ich habe Ihre Frage akustisch nicht
verstanden inwieweit ist einen
Unterschied macht das jetzt zu dritt
sind nee das im dauerkrisenmodus
regieren müssen das ist so viele Krisen
gibt ja ich meine das ich sage immer
dass diese die Zeit in der wir jetzt
leben die Herausforderungen die wir
jetzt haben sind die größten die wir
seit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges
hatten und das macht natürlich etwas mit
der Politik die Schnelllebigkeit mit der
diese Krisen auf uns zukommen macht auch
etwas mit der Politik und natürlich muss
das Ganze diese ganzen Vorhaben die sich
die Koalition vorgenommen hat in dem
Programm mehr Fortschritt Wagen jetzt im
im kriegsmodus in dem Koordinatensystem
das Krieges muss natürlich auch alles
finanziert werden das kommt auch noch
hinzu und ja das sind wirklich ganz
besondere Herausforderungen klar
der Kanzler hat ja eben sogar noch zum
mehr Fortschritt und mehr Tempo hat er
auch gesagt wir brauchen jetzt auch noch
mehr Zuversicht aber letztlich ist es ja
auch so als die Ampel damals diesen
Koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt hat mit
diesem großen Themen Digitalisierung
Energie da gab es ja damals schon die
Frage wer soll das alles bezahlen und
wie soll das finanziert werden und da
hieß es jetzt lasst uns erstmal machen
wir müssen jetzt erstmal loslegen fliegt
das der Regierung jetzt gerade um die
Ohren dass das nicht geklärt ist
ja das ist ein guter Punkt ich will mal
da noch mal ins Jahr 2017 zurückgehen
als wie die Jamaika Verhandlungen hatten
und die Jamaika Koalitionsverhandlungen
sind unter anderem auch deswegen
gescheitert weil man zu viel zu sehr
festzuren wollte also wirklich alles bis
ins kleinste
aushandeln um es dann einfach in
Anführungsstrichen sage ich mal
abzuarbeiten so funktionieren
Koalitionsverhandlungen aber nicht
deswegen sind sie ja auch gescheitert
daraus haben alle Akteure gelernt und
der Koalitionsvertrag 2021 hat
genügend Luft zum Atmen und man hat auch
auf das Vertrauen miteinander und diesen
fortschrittsgedanken dieses narrativ das
alle zusammenschnüren soll darauf hat
man gebaut dann kam aber die nächste
viel größere Krise noch als Corona
nämlich der Angriffskrieg Russlands in
der Ukraine und was auch noch hinzukommt
ist das ein Koalitionspartner nämlich
die FDP im letzten Jahr und jetzt auch
vor kurzem in der Berlin Wahl sehr
empfindliche Niederlagen in
Landtagswahlen ähm
verkraften musste und das verändert so
ein bisschen die Macht Arithmetik die
FDP versucht sich jetzt neu zu
profilieren hat
bisschen die Opposition in der Koalition
gespielt und es ist natürlich eine
Gemengelage die
schwierig ist aber das ist mein letzter
Punkt
wir alle haben es auch in den Zeiten der
großen Koalitionen verlernt oder
vielleicht auch vergessen dass
aushandeln das Streit eigentlich der
Kern einer jeden Demokratie ist es geht
darum unterschiedliche Positionen
auszuhandeln und im Idealfall dann so zu
einer besseren Lösung zu kommen also ein
Stück weit inhaltlicher
Auseinandersetzung ist nicht nur gut
sondern muss auch sein die Frage ist wie
viel so eine Koalition unter diesem
enormen Druck unter dem sie steht eben
auch aushält wenn wir in den Chat
schauen da wird das zum Teil wesentlich
negativer bewertet da schreibt Fett und
fit heißt wirklich so eigentlich weiß
jeder dass die Ampel bei der nächsten
Wahl abgewählt wird da schaut jede
Partei doch nur wie sie sich selbst
retten kann oder nicht Hanswurst
schreibt das war klar als man unbedingt
ins Amt wollte mit total
unterschiedlichen Ansichten oder
fair schreibt er hätte Dream Politiker
tun das wofür sie gewählt wurden ich war
in 50 Jahren selten so enttäuscht von
der Politik wie heute also vielleicht
zusammenfassend wenn Sie sich jetzt SPD
Grüne und FDP anschauen sie sagen das
Kurs ist normal ist auch wichtig aber
wer muss sich in welche Richtung wie
bewegen damit man da jetzt irgendwie
vorankommt
na also was ich mich in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten schon immer gefragt
habe ist warum die FDP so sehr an der
Schuldenbremse festhält wenn wir sie
schon in corona-zeiten ausgesetzt haben
und jetzt noch mal Herausforderungen
ganz andere Dimensionen haben
besteht meine Ansicht nach kein Grund
mehr an der Schuldenbremse festzuhalten
insofern meine ich dass ich die FDP hier
am meisten bewegen muss die FDP ist auch
noch in der ganz besonderen Zwickmühle
in Krisenzeiten wie wir sie in den
letzten Jahren erlebt haben erleben wir
auch die Rückkehr des starken Staates
und es ist genau das für die FDP eben
nicht steht
FDP steht für Freiheit für das
Individuum eben nicht für den starken
Staat insofern steht die FDP auch vor
der großen Frage wie sieht das liberale
wieder neu interpretiert um zurück zu
ihrer Frage zu kommen ich glaube die FDP
muss ich hier am meisten bewegen und
wir sehen ja auch hier dass hier die
großen Spannungslinien sind die große
die große auf Nervosität ist vielleicht
das bessere Wort die große Nervosität
auch ist weil wir noch drei
Landtagswahlen in diesem Jahr haben
Bremen Bayern und Hessen und da ist auch
die große Frage wie schneidet da die FDP
ab
ja da wird es auch im Chat geschrieben
da soll was zusammenarbeiten was nicht
zusammen passt die FDP muss aus dieser
Koalition raus oder sie wird
verschwinden oder eine die Meinung von
Simon die FDP ist die reinste
blockadepartei nur profilsüchtig sonst
nichts ist die FDP auch da in einem
wirklichen Dilemma
ja natürlich ist die FDP in einem in
einem Dilemma aber ich möchte noch mal
auf einen anderen Punkt zurückkommen den
sie gerade aus dem Chat vorgelesen haben
dass die Parteien ja nur an die an die
Macht wollen
er zum Glück haben die Parteien und
Politiker den Zug zur macht weil man nur
wenn man an der Macht ist auch gestalten
kann also das muss durchaus auch mal
muss durchaus auch gesehen werden
insofern ist der Zug zur macht durchaus
auch gut aber wie jetzt zu dritt
gestaltet werden kann und das ist nicht
nur auf die Kosten eines
Koalitionspartners geht das ist die
große Frage das war ja auch immer die
das große Dilemma der SPD in der großen
Koalition dass die positiven Ergebnisse
und Resultate auf das Konto des großen
Koalitionspartners nämlich Frau Merkel
einen bezahlt haben aber nicht auf die
SPD
sie haben die Pressekonferenz eben auch
gesehen
was war so ihr Gefühl was haben sie so
zwischen den Zeilen rausgehört
ja ich würde mich da Frau Diekmann voll
und ganze anschließen das hat sich heute
früh als drei Minister um 9 Uhr
praktisch den zweiten Klausurtag
eröffnet haben auch war das so der große
Thema es war Herr ähm Özdemir Clara
David und und Volker Wissing die eben
den Zusammenhalt und die gute Stimmung
das gute Miteinander ganz klar
hervorgehoben haben das haben wir jetzt
in der in der Abschlusspressekonferenz
auch wieder gehört man sprach sich
vertraut mit dem Vornamen an sagte die
wichtige Seite dass man sich auch
erstmal aus dem Alltagsgeschäft
zurückzieht und in Ruhe über Dinge
nachdenkt auch mal informell manche
Dinge bespricht stimmt sicherlich auch
aber wie gesagt der der große versuche
eine gewisse Einigkeit wieder zu
demonstrieren
abschließende Frage an Sie Frau römerle
und ich finde die sollte auch gestellt
werden was klappt denn gut bei der Ampel
ich finde die Ampel hat im ersten Jahr
durchaus geliefert in einem extrem
herausfordernden ja in dem Jahr der
Zeitenwende also haben wir unsere
Position was unsere
sicherheitspolitischen Maßnahmen unsere
sicherheitspolitische Position um 180
Grad
gedreht das Thema Mindestlohn Kindergeld
Wohngeld wurde auf den Weg gebracht
die große Frage wie kommen wir überhaupt
über den Winter haben wir gut gemeistert
flüssiggast Terminals Alter sind Dinge
die auf den Weg gebracht wurden
entlastungspakete findet es sind alles
Dinge die die Ampel eigentlich sehr gut
gemanagt hat es gab auch
Personalveränderungen die alles in allem
gut über die Bühne gegangen sind das
wäre auch immer Herausforderungen für
einen eine Koalition also alles in allem
gar kein schlechtes Zeugnis nach dem
ersten Jahr
und damit wollen wir es beschließen
vielen Dank für ihre Analyse Frau Müller
wünsche Ihnen noch eine schöne Woche
tschüss Ihnen auch tschüss
ja und damit machen wir Schluss für
heute verabschieden uns ZDF heute live
bis bald tschüss